this weekend tens of millions of people
in the United States and tens of
millions more around the world in
Columbus Georgia in Cardiff Wales and
Chongqing China in Chennai India will
leave their homes they'll get in their
cars or they'll take public
transportation or they will carry
themselves by foot and they'll step into
a room and sit down next to someone they
don't know or maybe someone they do and
the lights will go down and the watch a
movie
they'll watch movies about aliens or
robots or robot aliens or irregular
people but they will all be movies about
what it means to be human
millions will feel awe or fear millions
will laugh and millions will cry and
then the lights will come back on and
they'll reimagine to the world they knew
several hours prior and millions of
people will look at the world a little
bit differently than they did when they
went in like going to Temple or a mosque
or a church or any other religious
institution movie-going is in many ways
a sacred ritual repeated week after week
after week I'll be there this weekend
just like I was on most weekends between
the years of 1996 and 1998 the multiplex
near the shopping mall about five miles
from my childhood home in Columbus
Georgia the funny thing is that
somewhere between then and now I
accidently changed part of the
conversation about which of those movies
get made so the story actually begins in
2005 in an office high above Sunset
Boulevard where I was a junior executive
at Leonardo DiCaprio's production
company Appian Way and for those of you
who aren't familiar with how the film
industry works it basically means that I
was one of a few people behind the
person who produces the movie for the
people behind of in front of the camera
whose names you will better recognize
than mine essentially you're an
assistant movie producer who does
glamorous work that goes into the
creative aspect of producing a movie you
make lists of writers and directors and
actors you might be right for movies
that you want to will into existence you
meet with many of them and their
representatives hoping to curry favor
for some future date and you read a lot
three novels that might become movies
you read comic books that might become
movies you read articles that might
become movies you read scripts that
might become movies and you read scripts
from writers that might write the
adaptations of the novels of the comic
books of the articles and might rewrite
the scripts that you're already working
on all this in the hope of finding the
next big thing for the next big writer
who can deliver something that can make
you and your company the next big thing
so in 2005 I was a development executive
at Leonardo's production company I got a
phone call from the representative of a
screenwriter that began pretty much the
way all of those conversations did I've
got Leo's next movie and this movie that
his client had written Lea would play an
oil industry lobbyist his girlfriend a
local meteorologist threatens to leave
him because his work contributes to
global warming and this is a situation
that's been brought to a head by the
fact that there's a hurricane forming in
the Atlantic that's threatening to do
Maria like damage from Maine to Myrtle
Beach
Leo very sad about this impending
breakup there's a little more research
about the hurricane and discovers that
in its path across the Atlantic it will
pass over a long dormant or now active
volcano that will spew toxic ash into
its I that will presumably we've whipped
into some sort of chemical weapon that
will destroy the world
it was at that point that I asked him so
are you basically pitching me Leo versus
the toxic superstorm that will destroy
humanity and he responded by saying but
when you say it like that it sounds
ridiculous and I'm embarrassed to admit
that I had the guy send me the script
and I read 30 pages before I was sure
that it was as bad as I thought it was
now superstorm is certainly an extreme
example but it's also not an unusual one
and unfortunately most scripts are as
easy to dismiss as that one for example
a comedy about a high school senior who
when faced with an unplanned pregnancy
makes an unusual decision regarding her
unborn child that's obviously juno 230
million at the worldwide box office for
oscar nominations one win how about a
mumbai teen who grew up in the slums
wants to become a contestant on the
Indian version of Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire that's an easy one
it's from dog millionaire three hundred
and seventy seven million worldwide ten
Oscar nominations and eight wins a
chimpanzee tells his story of living
with the legendary pop star Michael
Jackson anyone it's a trick question but
it is a script called bubbles that is
going to be directed by Tycho ytt the
director of thor ragnarok so a large
part of your job as a development
executive is to separate these super
storms from these Slumdog Millionaire x'
and slightly more generally the writers
who write super storm from the writers
who can write Slumdog Millionaire and
the easiest way to do this obviously is
to read all of the scripts but that's
frankly impossible a good rule of thumb
is that the Writers Guild of America
registers about 50,000 new pieces of
material every year and most of them are
screenplays of those a reasonable
estimate is about 5000 of them make it
through various filters agencies
management companies screenplay
compositions and the like and a read by
someone at the production company or
major studio level and they're trying to
decide whether they can become one of
the 300 and dropping movies that are
released by the major studios or their
sub brands each year I've described it
before as being a little bit like
walking into a members-only bookstore
where the entire inventory is just
organized haphazardly and every book has
the same nondescript cover their job is
to
enter that bookstore and not come back
until you found the best and most
profitable books there its anarchic and
gleefully opaque and everyone has their
method to address these problems
you know most rely on the major agencies
and they just assume that if there's
great talent in the world they've
already found their way to the agencies
regardless of the structural barriers
that actually exist you getting to the
agencies in the first place
others also constantly compare notes
among themselves about what they've read
and what's good and they just hope that
their cohort group is the best most
wired and has the best taste in town and
others try to read everything but that's
again impossible if you're reading 500
screenplays in a year you are reading a
lot and it's still only a small
percentage of what's out there
fundamentally it's triage and when
you're in free oz you tend to default to
conventional wisdom about what works and
what doesn't that a comedy about a young
woman dealing with reproductive reality
can't sell that the story of an Indian
teenager is enviable in the domestic
market place or anywhere else in the
world outside of India that the only
source of viable movies is a very narrow
group of writers who have already found
their way to living and working in
Hollywood who already had the best
representation in the business and are
writing a very narrow band of stories
and I'm somewhat embarrassed to admit
that that's where I found myself in 2005
sitting in that office of both Sunset
Boulevard staring down that metaphorical
and autumn eyes bookstore and having
read nothing but bad scripts for months
I took this to mean one of two things
either a I was not very good at my job
which was ostensibly finding good
scripts or be reading bad scripts was
the job in which case my mother's weekly
phone calls asking me if my law school
infant's exam scores were still valid
was something I should probably pay more
attention to what I also knew was that I
was about to go on vacation for two
weeks and as bad as reading bad scripts
is when it is your job it's even more
painful on vacation
so I had to do something so late one
night in my office I made a list of
everyone that I had had breakfast lunch
dinner or drinks with I had jobs similar
to mine and I sent them an anonymous
email and I made a very simple request
send me a list of up to ten
favourite screenplays that meet three
criteria one you love the screenplay to
the filmed version of that screenplay
will not be in theaters by the end of
that calendar year and three you found
out about the screenplay this year this
was not an appeal for the scripts that
would be the next great blockbuster on
an appeal for the scripts that would win
the Academy Award if they didn't need to
be scripts that their bosses loved or
that their studio wanted to make it was
very simply an opportunity for people to
speak their minds about what they loved
which in this world is increasingly rare
now almost all the 75 people I emailed
anonymously responded and then two dozen
other people actually emailed to
participate to this anonymous email
address but I confirm it they didn't
have to have the jobs they claimed to
have and I then compiled the votes into
a spreadsheet ran a pivot table I'll put
it to PowerPoint and the night before I
left for vacation I slapped a quasi
subversive name on it and emailed it
back from that anonymous email address
to everyone who voted the blacklist a
tribute to those who lost their careers
during the anti-communist hysteria of
the 1940s and 50s and a conscious
inversion of the notion that black
somehow had a negative connotation after
arriving in Mexico pulled out a chair by
the pool started reading these scripts
and found to my shock and joy that most
of them were actually quite good mission
accomplished what I didn't and couldn't
have expected was what happened next
about a week into my time on vacation I
stopped by the hotels business center to
check my email this is a pre iPhone
world after all and found that this list
that I have created anonymously have
been forwarded back to me several dozen
times in my personal email address
everyone was sharing this list of
scripts that everyone had said that they
loved reading them and then loving them
themselves my first reaction but I can't
actually say here but will describe it
as fear the idea of surveying people
about their scripts was certainly not a
novel or a genius one surely there was
some unwritten Hollywood rule of America
that had guided people away from doing
that before that I was simply too naive
to understand it being so early in my
career I was sure I was going to get
fired and so I decided that day that AI
would never tell anybody that I had done
this and B I would never do it
been six months later something even
more bizarre happened I was in my office
on Sunset and got a phone call from
another writers agent call began very
similarly to the call about superstorm
I've got Leo's next movie now that's not
the interesting part the interesting
part is the way the call ended because
this agent then told me and I quote
don't tell anybody
but I have it on really good authority
this was gonna be the number one script
on next year's blacklist yeah suffice it
to say I was dumbfounded here was an
agent using the blacklist this thing
that I had made anonymously and it was
decided to never make again to sell his
client to me to suggest that the script
had merit based solely on the
possibility of being looted on a list of
beloved screenplays after the call ended
I sat in my office or staring out the
window alternating between shock and
general giddiness
and then I realized that this thing that
I created had a lot more value than just
me finding good screenplays to read over
the holidays and so I did it again the
next year and the LA Times outed me as a
person who had created it and the year
after that and the year after that and
I've done it every year since 2005 and
the results have been fascinating
because unapologetic line aside this
agent was exactly right this list was
evidenced to many people of a scripts
value and that a great script had
greater value that I think a lot of
people had previously anticipated very
quickly the writers new scripts were on
that list started getting jobs those
scripts started getting made and those
scripts that got made were often the
ones that violated the assumptions about
what worked and what didn't they were
scripts like Juno and Little Miss
Sunshine and the Queen and the King's
Speech and spotlight and yes Slumdog
Millionaire and even an upcoming movie
about Michael Jackson's chimpanzee now I
think it's really important that I
paused here for a second and say that I
can't take credit for the success of any
of those movies I didn't write them I
didn't direct them I didn't produce them
I didn't gaff them they'd make food and
craft service we all know how important
that is
but credit for those movies the credit
for that's
sass goes to the people who made the
films what I did was change the way
people looked at them accidentally I
asked if the conventional wisdom was
correct and certainly there are movies
on that list that would have gotten made
without the blacklist but there are many
that definitely would not have and at a
minimum we've catalyzed a lot of them
into production and I think that's worth
noting there had been about a thousand
screenplays on the blacklist since its
inception in 2005 about three hundred
and twenty five have been produced
they've been nominated for 300 Academy
Awards they've won fifty four of the
last nine best pictures have gone to
scripts from the blacklist and ten of
the last 20 screenplay Oscars have gone
description the blacklist all told
they've made about twenty five billion
dollars in worldwide box office which
means that hundreds of millions of
people have seen these films when they
leave their homes and sitting next to
someone they don't know and the lights
go down and that's to say nothing into
post theatrical environments like DVD
streaming and let's be honest illegal
downloads five years ago today October
15th my business partner and I doubled
down on this notion that screenwriting
talent was not where we expected to find
it and we launched a website that would
allow anybody on earth who written an
english-language screenplay to upload
their scripts have it evaluated to make
it available to thousands of the film
industry professionals and I'm pleased
to say in the five years since its
launched we've largely proved that
thisis hundreds of riders from across
the world a found representation have
had that work optioned or sold seven
have even seen their films made in the
last three years including the film
Nightingale the story of a war veteran
psychological decline in which David a
yellow bows face is the only one on
screen for the film's 90-minute duration
it was nominated for a Golden Globe and
two Emmy Awards it's also kind of cool
that more than a dozen writers who were
discovered on the website have ended up
on this end of year annual list
including two of the last three number
one writers simply put the conventional
wisdom about screenwriting merit where
it was and where it could be found was
wrong and this is notable because as I
mentioned before in the triage of
finding movies to make and making them
there's a lot of reliant on conventional
wisdom and that conventional wisdom
maybe just maybe might be wrong to even
greater consequence films about black
people don't sell overseas a few motive
and action movies don't work because
women will see themselves in men but men
won't see themselves in women but no one
wants to see movies about women over 40
that our on-screen heroes have to
conform to a very narrow idea about
beauty that we consider conventional
what does that mean when those images
are projected 30 feet high and the
lights go down for a kid that looks like
me in Columbus Georgia or a Muslim girl
in Cardiff Wales or a gay kid in Chennai
what does it mean for how we see
ourselves and how we see the world and
for how the world sees us we live in
very strange times but I think for the
most part we all live in a state of
constant triage there's just too much
information too much stuff to contend
with and so as a rule we tend to default
to conventional wisdom I think it's
important that we ask ourselves
constantly how much of that conventional
wisdom is all convention and no wisdom
and at what cost thank you
[Applause]
[Music]